Colorado and Maine have ruled that
Donald Trump does not qualify for the
ballot because of his involvement in
January 6th while these states have
either dismissed similar cases or still
have them pending now Trump has asked
the Supreme Court to weigh in the case
hinges on this part of the 14th
Amendment section three that says no
person shall hold any office who having
previously taken an oath have engaged in
Insurrection or Rebellion it seems
pretty straightforward but Scholars say
this language raises a lot of questions
does that apply to the president of the
United States what does it mean to have
engaged in Insurrection or Rebellion
against the United States you and how do
you determine whether someone has done
that or not here's the history behind
this amendment how it's been used in the
past and what questions it could bring
to the Supreme
Court the 14th Amendment is the most
important Amendment ever added to the
Constitution or certainly since the Bill
of Rights you might say that it's an
attempt to put into the
Constitution some of the ma major
results of the Civil War this is Eric
foner he's written a lot on the 14th
Amendment and the time period in which
it was created he's the sort of
specialist on the Civil War and
reconstruction period one of his books
was even cited in the Colorado Supreme
Court's ruling my publisher was ecstatic
they they really think it's going to
lead to a lot of sales which I'm not so
sure about and in that book he details
the origins of the 14th Amendment the
one that established Birthright
citizenship equal protection under the
law how representatives are apportioned
oddly the debt ceiling but also this
section three barring Confederates who
served from serving again most northern
Republicans the Victorious people in the
Civil War thought that the 14th
amendment was absolutely essential uh to
making sure that the victory in the
Civil War of the nation was consolidated
and that the former Confederates didn't
come into power again I think white
Southerners saw Section 3 as a
punishment and while these sections were
fiercely debated in Congress and
throughout the country there's almost no
debate about Section 3 in fact the
debate about section three was should
the penalty be that they could not hold
office or should the penalty be that
these folks could not have the right to
vote they eventually agreed on just
barring from office at first it was
formally invoked just a few times to
remove Confederates subsequently in
American history on occasion it was
enforced but very very rarely most
notably is Victor L Berger a congressman
and co-founder of the Socialist Party he
was elected in 1918 after being indicted
for Espionage now by the way the
Espionage Act it's important to say had
nothing to do with Espionage the way we
understand it it was just if you oppos
the war they threw you in jail Berger
did oppose the war so Congress invoked
section three and refused to seat him
the Supreme Court went on to overturn
his Espionage conviction and then he was
seated in Congress and eventually serve
two more terms they said well if there's
no evidence that he did give a or
Comfort to the enemies of the United
States now so therefore we can't deny
him the right to hold office so that
raises the first questions for the
Supreme Court what qualifies as an
Insurrection today how do we know
someone did that are they going to get a
trial by jury
is it just an administrative thing where
some committee well look here's the film
and you're in there is that a Judicial
proceeding is that a political
proceeding and does it require a
criminal conviction Trump is charged
with a lot of things in the January 6
case but Insurrection isn't one of them
and the trial hasn't even begun one
person involved in January 6th has been
unseated due to section 3 a New Mexico
county commissioner so an officer who
took an oath was convicted of
trespassing on January 6th and and
served time in jail it's a great day for
America he was removed from office under
Section 3 but the judge specifically
mentioned that he would have been
removed regardless of whether he'd been
convicted of any crime another important
question does section 3 even apply to
the president Senator representative in
Congress elector for president for vice
president um or civil or military office
under the United States or under any
state is the president an officer under
the United States doesn't mention the
president but it doesn't exclude the
president either another question who
enforces this in these past examples it
was either enforced by the Judiciary or
congress decided to not seat someone but
can it be enforced on a ballot this is
not barring you from running it is
barring you from hold from winning I
guess from holding office there's not a
Juris Prudence about this and trying to
judge the modern-day interpretation of
the original intent of the amendment is
tricky if you are searching for the one
original intent or the one original
meaning you are never going to get
anywhere because there was so much
desenti there were disagreement there
were compromises so the lack of
specificity in the amendment and the
scarcity of case law since it was
ratified means there's a lot of ways the
Supreme Court could interpret this law
and a lot of questions for them to
answer